after 26 days in the jungle of fiji we
finally have a survivor 42 winner
yes for the love of god the next soul
survivor was crowned after an intense
three-hour finale where the final
castaways were grilled by the jury yeah
and of course it wouldn't be survivor
without
one final twist take a look and warning
major spoilers ahead
there's one more twist this season stop
it stop it because we shoot our seasons
back to back you don't know
anything that happened in survivor 41
and what we did in survivor 41 was
we read the votes in the jungles of fiji
and that's what we're going to do right
now
we're going to read these votes
we're going to crown a winner of
survivor 42
are we ready yeah
yeah
good luck good luck you too i hope you
guys yes oh here we go
come on chef wow
[Music]
first vote
mike
[Music]
marianne one vote marianne one vote mike
marianne two votes marianne one vote
mike
marianne three votes marianne one vote
mike
mariam that's four votes marianne one
vote mike
the winner of survivor 42
marianne
that's five that's enough here we go
come on over jury
come on over
and of course we are joined by our one
and only survivor correspondent season
41 winner erica erica another canadian
winner how does it feel to pass on the
survivor crown to marianne i'm so
excited the crown is still in canada
it's pretty cool eh
okay but before final tribal council two
castaways still had to get the chop and
during the episode's first tribal mike
decided to use his idol on marianne
after securing safety at the immunity
challenge so erica do you think that was
a good move on his end
when i was watching the show i was kind
of confused about this one but when i
spoke to mike today he said he really
wanted to prove his loyalty to mary ann
and i think that that might have been a
more performative move versus something
that moves him forward in the game but i
think it was great for marianne because
during tribal council there was a moment
when mike gives her the idol
she looks at the jury with the look that
says do you see this grown man using his
advantage to save me that is marion's
power okay now after both lindsay and
jonathan were sent to the jury marianne
mike and romeo were the three left
standing at final tribal council so
erica in your opinion what makes a good
final tribal well i think that maybe i'm
crazy i actually love final tribal maybe
it's because i worked in pr for so many
years before but final tribal it's a
tricky dance and balance of many things
but in the end it's really like an
elementary school essay where you say
your thesis and then you prove how you
you did your thesis so you say this is
what i intended to do and this is how i
did it i think the problem is sometimes
people want to say that they intended to
do the best but with what they did they
kind of fall short so you don't always
have to go hard and be up here if you
say i wanted to do this and then i did
this the jury will respect that
interesting
yeah now some of the jury members really
came for romeo mike and marianne
how do you think each of them performed
during final tribal
i think romeo did great i think that
romeo when i spoke to him he said he
knew he was playing for second place and
i think he did great about knowing he
was in a bad position and knowing that
he had to do what he could to just keep
going and i think that he also really
owned that he grew personally so much in
the game so i was really happy with how
romeo did
mike had a rough time
mike went into it saying that he was
going to play with integrity that he was
a man of his word and when you make a
claim that big it's easy for the jury to
come to you and say you lied about this
you did this you did this so i think
mike struggled and then marianne of
course
killed it she was someone who was
underestimated came in made great points
showed people she had an advantage that
was hidden that no one knew about i
think she slayed she did awesome i was
so proud of her okay now can we talk
about the fact that we have a canadian
winning streak going right now on
survivor
it is epic let's go i think that people
need to be afraid when they see
canadians on survivor from now on and
earlier today i caught up with marianne
to talk about her big win
i need to ask you
why are canadians so good at survivor
specifically canadian women there's
something in the water there's got to be
something in the water about like why
we're good and i think the thing in the
water we've and we've been wanting to
play this game for so long and you know
we were finally allowed to play we're
like what we're gonna play we're gonna
show that we earned it and we've taken
it two seasons in a row i think people
need to be scared i think that people
underestimate nice canadians but you
should be scared if you see a canadian
on the beach someone says a boot you
boot them out
that's right eh oh yeah
you're so great that's amazing though
with the two of you
there was a drought where there wasn't a
woman winner for years and then all of a
sudden canadian women are on the show
look what happens